so we were seeing more and more of this
pejorative use of the term Chinese virus
from Donald Trump to refer to the corona
virus that's bad enough and it's growing
daily Donald Trump seems to sort of be
getting energy from it and and really
enjoying using it but we're also now
hearing from an Asian reporter that a
trump official referred to the virus as
the Kung flu to her face we're talking
about Wei Jia yang Jang who is a CBS
News White House correspondent she
tweeted yesterday that quote this
morning a White House official referred
to coronavirus as the cun flew to my
face makes me wonder what they're
calling it behind my back
meanwhile again Donald Trump seems to
have realized that Chinese virus is
working well for him in terms of
propaganda and currying favor with his
supporters and he's constantly tweeting
about it now just in the last few hours
Donald Trump tweeted quote I always
treated the Chinese virus very seriously
and have done a very good job from the
beginning including my very early
decision to close the borders from China
as well as saying this morning I will be
having a news conference today to
discuss very important news from the FDA
concerning the Chinese virus and then an
hour before that for the people that are
now out of work because of the important
and necessary containment policies for
instance the shutting down of hotels
bars and restaurants money will soon be
coming to you the onslaught of the
Chinese virus is not your fault now
there are people saying we should call
it the Chinese virus because the Spanish
flu was called the Spanish flu and we
call things what they are even that
assessment ignores history the 1918 flu
sometimes called the Spanish flu didn't
start in Spain and it didn't really have
anything to do with Spain the Spanish
flu started in either Kansas France or
China it was called the Spanish flu by
the Allies in World War one because it
got more attention when it moved from
France to Spain in November of 1918 in
the same way if anything we would be
calling this the European flu because it
became more quickly prevalent around the
world once it got to Europe and that
really became the epicenter it did
originate in China China had an
explosion of cases now under control in
China Europe is really the focus of the
worldwide spread if things continue as
European countries get under control to
explode in the US this may soon be the
us of flu the u.s. virus by the way but
in any case you know when you start
hearing things like kung flu Chinese
virus you know you're losing the fight
against the virus and you're instead
choosing to fight a propaganda war and
the reality is wherever it started like
listen if the governor of Oklahoma is
bragging about going out to restaurants
when we should be self isolating it
doesn't matter whether it started in
China France Italy Australia or Peru
right it just doesn't matter we are
spreading it here and we are causing the
problem to get even worse and that's
ultimately what matters and at the rate
things are going and from the email I'm
actually I actually got a message
yesterday from someone who said well
someone eye nose roommate is just
pretending like nothing's going on
they're just going about their day
they're annoyed that their favorite
restaurants are takeout only and they
think the entire thing is just a hoax
that's here in Massachusetts just
imagine what is going on and how
prevalent that is in a red state like
Oklahoma where the governor is publicly
minimizing it and bragging about being
with his kids out to dinner at a packed
restaurant we're just not going to solve
it if that's the case and people will
die unnecessarily this is not you know
lying about I cut the deficit when you
didn't that's bad enough but this this
is life and death for a lot of people
and every single day the death toll is
climbing and it's not slowing down
unfortunately I want to give a quick
shout-out to one of our sponsors VIN
Charo watches they're giving my audience
15% off your entire order when you go to
david pakman.com slash watch maybe you
don't usually wear a watch and you've
been thinking about looking for one to
elevate your look or you've been
thinking about replacing the one you
have check out VIN Charo it's an
American company all of their watches
are built in small batches from high-end
materials they look
amazing and they look like something
you'd spend a lot of money on but ever
even Cheryl watch ranges from a hundred
and fifty to three hundred dollars I
went on their website and picked out the
Kairos in white and silver really loved
the look the combination of the white
face and the beige band really loved
this one they also sent me the Kairos
limited release gold reserve set totally
different style this one would make a
fantastic gift for a couple people I can
think of in my family any time you see
me wearing a watch on the show I'm
wearing a Ventura watch go through their
collection I know you'll find something
you like and you'll get 15% off when you
go to david pakman.com slash watch